la direction à présent la russie pour la
troisième et avant-dernière journée du
24e forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg plusieurs milliers de
chefs d'entreprises et d'acteurs
politiques sont réunis en cette fin de
semaine pour échanger sur le monde de
l'économie de la praye qu'ovide avec une
sortie attendue cet après midi celle du
président russe vladimir poutine
[Musique]
on retrouve tout de suite verhaeghe
hoffman en direct de saint pétersbourg
verra quel est le programme
aujourd'hui le président russe doit
s'exprimer
bonjour dévorer oui effectivement le
programme du forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg à s'annonce très
chargé aujourd'hui avec pour l'événement
central c'est la session plénière avec
la participation en personne du
président russe vladimir poutine
d'autres invités qui sont prévus pour
participer à cette session plénière
c'est le c'est l'émir du qatar al thani
lui le le chancelier fédéral autrichien
sébastien coste qui vont participer
envie de conférence il ya aussi une
déclaration du président de l'argentine
qui est prévue du président du brésil
qui est prévu et également c'est une
déclaration va être diffusée pendant
cette session plénière ensuite ça va
être le tour de la discussion des
participants à cette session plénière
ensuite et un programme que du président
russe qui continue y va a notamment
rencontré des chefs d'entreprises
étrangères il va répondre à leurs
questions il va partager sa vision
concernant les investissements en russie
ensuite le président russe doit
rencontrer des représentants des
entreprises étrangères qui produit déjà
on vont produire le vaccin risque ou
nick v et ensuite pendant la soirée de
lundi mais poutine doit rencontrer des
chefs des agences de presse pour dans
une session questions réponses hui va
justement répondre aux questions
concernant la politique étrangère et
intérieure russes
merci verhaeghe hoffman pour toutes ces
précisions direct de saint pétersbourg
et on vous retrouve évidemment tout au
long de cette journée
[Musique]